hello everybody and welcome to part 16
of let's play penumbra overture where we
last left off I went into a useless
shaft 12 oh the nerve where I found
nothing except that note that was like
10 billion pages long
oh so annoying all right went to the
refinery for no good reason
time to go chef 13 map map where am I
there I am okay
easy enough wait what's this refinery
again like I need to go there oh right
jam the doors shut with my massive
muscles okay chef 13 yep
all right Oh chair no nothing absolutely
dick diddly
let's see what's back here if anything
anything oh I forgot ah yeah I
remembered a lot of people are saying
that I'm not using these enough because
it's way too dark in the movie sorry
about that sorry
ok victory flash yeah oh right what we
got here Oh hole I go in there yeah I'll
stick around as long as I want you shut
up uh-huh I'll ship them I'll ship them
come here Comair huh hair I'm gonna I
swear I will oh you son of a [ __ ] all
right
oh this way oh is that acid yeah
whatever I'm too tough for acid anyway I
got an alkaline skin yeah ah ah no oh
why is this trying to pick trying to
kill me oh shut up John stop being such
a [ __ ] all right yeah this doesn't look
like a death crap Oh eggs
Oh spiders no no spiders that's right I
hear chitter-chatter no spires no spud
ah I just biter I just said no spires oh
go away spider go away I don't even
ah yeah yeah oh God
bro ah that's more hair autos are the
dead end oh ok that's dumb you go away
spider one likes you anyway you're ugly
you're bad at parties and stuff once
here
oh it's more eggs hatching that's more
attention thanks I think
I don't get it hey guys Oh what oh so
pro ah get away get away get away get
away get away get away
oh yeah ah eggs oh I hate this place I
hate it so go away fire
go get [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I gotta die
again fighter get away get away get away
get away get away
oh thank you oh I have none ah ah ok
alright getting right back into I'm not
gonna let it get me down nothing's gonna
get me
left left again all there's a spider or
woo just keep running don't even oh no
not the dead end at the dead end at the
dead end
okay all right keep going keep going go
ahh music shut up shut up shut up music
oh right moving making from all ya I'll
open tail and a chair you're so dead
spider Oh bring it on
BAM Oh what was that stopped in your
tracks yeah oh you can't jump can don't
even try
yeah just shop yeah get down you son
Oh Oh monkey Oh beat you into the ground
oh I'm so strong yeah give me that give
me that
I never even use one of those anyway all
batteries yet painkiller finally glad I
died otherwise I'd have to use that oh
that's what was holding it back Oh as if
that's gonna stop me
whoo sorry about this [ __ ] throw
everybody
right we we got here Oh last will and
testament last Health three other miners
had a trap but haha uh-oh
so much words security code oh is it
gonna be security good oc3 got it
Oh normal ah 1 2 norm I okay two letters
- 2 - 3 - black obviously that's known
as 10 I don't even know well set and a
blank fourth page why why
nevermind I'm going crazy
shut up Billy yeah yeah
no kidding
and we think this is tf2 oh shut up bill
I can't even hear you yeah of course of
course it would be blocked off what's
back there oh it's back there nothing
more nothing oh okay oh I so bet there's
gonna be a spider jumping out get out of
here
oh yeah blank note fantastic get boots
uh-oh
so strong yeah beef jerky gimme gimme
nothing once again nothing nothing at
all like everything everything at all
rocks all piles sink
but no kidding John Oh God your
observation sucks so bad
all right I'm out of here I'm out of
here get let me through
Ryan stopping Oh what do I gotta do oh
no code written on it oh wait a minute
save for smears of dirt I will all yeah
I know I know I'm like oh so ah what was
that I got out here ah ah dude buddy
Wow in my chair ah here we go oh yeah
it's time God my mouth [ __ ] up mouse
mouse you [ __ ] up on me get just die
just get squished squish squish squish
squish squish ah
give me a measure give me crush just
squish already oh I hate you so much I
hate you
oh yeah ah ah ah [ __ ] up butters I hate
you I hate everything about you
everything everything about you oh just
go oh no why why why why why
oh no oh no no no no no no aah come on
aah this is this is the worst this is
the work I went down there dead end
again oh this is the worst oh this is so
bad oh you're all laughing at me aren't
you you are I pop yo jerks no you're not
aah I love each and every one none of
you are jerks I don't blame you I blame
the spiders I'm just mad sorry I lashed
out get out of here
oh come on block that entrance up with
your clip
oh so strong
yep BAM oh yeah there we go
Oh God jiminy Christmas
all right throwing these lockers I've
been getting Oh all batteries yay Oh
painkillers oh it's a good thing that
died cuz then I would have to use them
Oh a note okay Oh blank no why is there
a blank for page all right let's see oh
is this a way out oh okay who lockers
is there something useful oh oh oh book
oh shut up Billy oh shut up Billy oh
you're so stupid Billy ah
oh look dynamite Oh a hat what do you
think this is tf2 Oh what's this Oh Rock
tiles
Oh what's through there nothing hold on
another Oh brown water Oh John you so
dumb lockers I'll throw them open with
my massive muscles all right think I'm
caught up now hat again nope yeah like
though oh why is it blank
oh shoot get out here shoe chair get on
my way you didn't help me at all it's C
it was No
that's beef jerky okay the idea that I
had was to dip this in the water oh shut
up John it was dirty I thought it could
clean it fine
oh can I burn it burn it shut up
broom it off screw drive it flare it up
kill its pain jerky it's beef I don't
know whatever get my way all right that
was it I swear there's nothing else
nothing possibly I'm out of here
I'm sad ah aggravation huh okay victory
flash another perfectly a good reason
I've just come and collecting notes oh
where do I go what do i do what do I do
ah lever I'll shut up worm was this do
ha
yes steam that's phenomenal uh open up
Oh what was the point of that seriously
what's the point of that
Oh what is the point of this do I put
steam the shut-off maybe Oh steam will
reveal a code of some sort
uh uh ha ha hi burns ah oh did that hurt
no not even a little bit aw so huh did
it work your work no it did not work of
course it didn't why why would it work
all they do quite a [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you oh I have to pause it here guys
sorry about the lack of progress I'm so
stupid
okay alright thanks so much for watching
I will see you in part 17 yes 17 of
let's play penumbra overture bye bye